Don Cherry did a bunch of interviews
yesterday after he was fired by Sports
Net for refusing to apologize for his
you people rant on Coach's Corner
one of those interviewers is getting a
lot of attention because Don appeared on
Fox News's Tucker Carlson the one thing
that got me and they was you people and
I suppose if I had it to do over again I
would have said everybody but you people
are the people that they listened to the
silent majority as you know are always
silent the police are with me that the
forces are with me everybody's with me
and the firefighters the whole deal but
doesn't make any sense and I was brought
in and I was told that I was fired after
38 years and you know I stand by what I
said and I still mean it it's the two
words that that got it that you people
and as you know people are very
sensitive like that and that's the big
ivy but I I well they're not they're not
sensitive at all they're fascists
they're not they actually have no real
feelings they're faking they're outraged
they're trying to crush you because they
wanted to desert power because it makes
them feel big wouldn't actually inside
they're small but you just to clarify
you didn't did you mean to say something
hateful no I didn't and you know and and
we're all immigrants in the whole deal
of interesting comment by Tucker Carlson
yeah so here's my thing now like okay
his original thing was I didn't mean
what I said right right but so sports
like give him the opportunity to
apologize done decided no we don't know
how to present the details behind that
though yeah oh yeah we don't know what
they wanted him to do but they're
willing to give him a form to correct
something right but it's never been said
exactly sports that has not said he but
they didn't say he could have kept his
well that's true he might have been
under the impression that there was
something that he could have done right
but they did say in their statement
after further talks with Don was implied
yet they were gonna give him some kind
of form to apologize and he chose not to
apologize and losers don't like my thing
is that whatever we know if that's the
case though I don't know because he said
he said many different things in many
different interviews yesterday and I
don't know if that is 100% the story
right
like my thing is like we did this live
show obviously we've never said
something that terrible on the show
button right there is a possibility
where ever you could use the wrong word
have a slip-up if you get the reaction
that you know some new immigrants are
upset by what you're saying if that's
not what you intended at all my reaction
be oh my goodness I can't believe people
are interpreting that way yes give me
the chance to clear that SAP look clear
it up his decision was no no I want to
lose my job instead I don't know I don't
know
I don't I don't know if that's the
because it may not have been just
apologize it may have been something
that he was not willing to do and that
other people have not been willing to
it's okay but but if you got if you
heard that you'd really upset a certain
group of people you wouldn't want to you
normally no no I'll lose my job I don't
want to crack that yeah but he does it
but the thing that Don has always said
in all of the interviews is that he
meant what he liked he meant what he
meant it was just the wrong words right
so so why would she want to correct that
and keep your job because maybe they
maybe they said that wasn't good enough
maybe he then had to say I take
everything back that I said which is
what he wasn't willing to do yeah maybe
yeah you don't know how far is gonna go
but then so then you're gonna lose your
job and now you're gonna go on Fox News
and especially if all on all shows the
Fox News tiger calls also so who's got
so much backlash loss advertisers we we
won't get in what Tucker Carlson has
done in history but yeah like this is
the road we're going down now Donnelly
you've made a clear choice here you
decided I'm not gonna clear up what I
said and clarified that I wasn't going
to get immigrants I'm gonna go on Fox
News Talk just a whole different road
now we're going down for sure but
there's things that you can't deny about
Fox News and believe me I'm not saying
it for Fox News but if you want a giant
platform that's the show to go on right
yeah well you know what I mean like if
you want to get the word out to as many
people as you can to do the biggest show
you can that's the biggest show on cable
it's huge the optics like this is not
the show to go well no because if you're
being accused and this is why the optics
do look so bad because if you are being
accused of being racist and
anti-immigrant and everything else the
one place you may not want to run to
raise Tucker cross yeah that's what Lisa
says Tucker Carlson really that's who
you speak to drive your racing you go to
somebody who's gonna challenge you but
still give you an opportunity to say
what you felt
yeah that's where you go I don't know if
you necessarily go to Sanders's we're
all immigrants by populous before it
yeah that's unless he can walk he can
walk back that you people all he wants
and he can say that he means everybody
but the two words you people were not
the ones that I feel hurt the most from
what I've when I've talked to people
it's the you come here yeah three words
like are yeah yeah are the other yes
there wasn't people we can all week
we're all you people tonight we can all
fit into some category of you people but
it was you come here and that was the I
think that was the real problem in or
even says I agree with Don acetyl zoo
when I know that I don't agree that Don
should have been fired